coming this summer
they're finally going to make a movie
about me the story of Batman's greatest
ally it's me that must be me and best
friend in the whole world
the movie is time to clean up this city
that actually does look pretty good
they're really making movies about it
every superhero has there been a movie
about you it was a Green Lantern movie
but we don't we don't talk about that
it's time they make one about me I'm
afraid it's no I only make movies about
real superheroes why don't they take us
seriously Titans you guys are never
actually doing anything heroic that
wasn't even a crime and you didn't save
anything we say brutal design having a
movie is the only way to be seen as a
real hero what about an arch-nemesis
stop right there Deadpool Deadpool what
why does everything I'm Deadpool
I thought Deadpool was a good guy by the
way he should be saying that he's not me
okay cuz I came out like way before he
did no I'm pretty sure you're Deadpool
if we can make you more arch-nemesis
then they can see that we're worthy of a
movie sidekick and a half a robot
oh man I'm never letting you fly my body
again
we're taking you down how are you gonna
do it we need a part of me whatever
dance-off
you're gonna annoy me to death with your
waffles
you